is great to be joined once again by luke
vargas united nations bureau chief for
talk media news he was at yesterday's
presidential debate the first
presidential debate Luke we've been
talking about it pretty extensively on
today's show I know that you have a
number of different angles that you're
going to add for us first thought I've
given some of my high and low points for
both candidates I thought generally most
of trumps strong points were uh very
very overwhelmingly stacked at the
beginning of the debate I'll open up the
floor to you and see what your
impression was think I'm probably going
to agree with you at least on that last
point I'll say overall I think this
debate went as well as it possibly could
have for Hillary Clinton and we're
talking about this some concern on the
part of the Clinton campaign and some
Clinton supporters going into Monday's
debate was that this was going to be
graded on a curve instead I think pretty
clear to most people who were there
watching it in the press corps and it
seems to be the buzz on the street is
that Hillary Clinton hurtled over a
pretty high bar and Donald Trump seemed
to trip over a relatively low bar you
know as far as strength for each
candidate I think Hillary's big strength
was her preparation the fact that you
know people were saying she's a
difficult task out there probably the
policy part will be easy but it's going
to be actually having the right effect
the right presentation as a way of
countering Donald Trump and I think she
succeeded in that really well I'm her
campaign obviously spun this going into
the debate saying yes she has been
taking this seriously she spent a few
weeks working on this and I think it
showed in particular she was able to be
cool calm and collected the three big
things he always wants or than a
presidential demeanor I'm but at the
same time knew when to try and get under
Donald Trump skin it's been reported by
Ezra Klein and others that Donald
Trump's children and most of the people
at his company's sort of have a habit
and he's used to them calling him mr.
Trump and other very formal titles and I
think Hillary Clinton was very smart
here to say look whatever about decorum
I don't need to call him mr. Trump and
just fall into that I'm gonna call him
Donald and I think there was ample
evidence last night that was one of a
few things that she did that when she
was speaking subtly sort of got him out
of his groove and I think that balance
in addition also knowing sort of when
she was on the split screen and that she
shouldn't just turn off her presentation
when she wasn't answering a question
really showed that the debate
preparation was one of her big strengths
I'll say very quickly about Donald Trump
I think the best thing he did is what
he's been doing best all along granted
it's taking up less and less time with
in debates but he continues to be strong
on free trade he continues I think to
resonate with voters in key states key
constituencies when it comes to economic
sort of dislocation in the modern age
when we're talking about crumbling
American infrastructure he speaks about
it with a passion and I think in a
thority that you know people resonate
with and it's worth pointing out I've
heard this a lot over the last week sort
of a revisionist history on the part of
Democrats that oh you know in 2008
Barack Obama was able to win because he
was offering up an end of American
military adventurism that it was a
referendum on pulling the troops out of
Iraq and Afghanistan went back and
looked at Paul's going into election day
in 2008 John McCain was ahead handily
when it came to foreign policy it was
the fact that on issues that really
concerned Americans about the economy of
course in the midst of an economic
disaster at that time that was the big
issue that got brock obama into office
so i think again issues of trade and
these other things may only take up a
few minutes in the debate but Hillary
Clinton needs to figure out a way to
neutralize him on those issues uh
because I think they they have an
outsized influence when it comes down to
who's actually going to decide this
election yeah I did earlier my and it
wasn't tongue in cheek it's a just that
the best Trump moments were still not
that good but one of the one of the
three that I had was related to NAFTA
and how he was actually able to still
without really giving any policy
prescriptions which he he almost
completely avoided in the debate he was
at least able to optically come across
as strong and more sort of determined in
a sense than Hillary Clinton now you
talked about the preparation part as far
as Hillary Clinton is concerned this
sort of relates to you mentioned body
language knowing when she was on a split
screen or really just I think assuming
she she was on a split screen the entire
time acting as if she was how did the
Trump into
options play in the room I think they're
a bit jarring I mean on some of them he
really just seemed to be unable to
stifle himself there was a point when
Lester Holt to reach ass ties him and
said this is hillary clinton's question
and not ten seconds later he was asking
Lester Holt a question about Hillary
Clinton's answer as she was answering I
mean he really that was not just a
little violation it was responded to you
know a slap on the wrist with a much
more serious infraction of the rules of
the debate so I found that to be quite
strange I found I mean again Donald
Trump says he did not prepare for this
debate I don't believe that in fact you
look at some of the people who's brought
on to his campaign in recent weeks
someone like Roger Ailes in particular
who's been in the business of preparing
candidates for their you know television
debates for decades now and by all
accounts relatively good at that but I
think he may have spent too much time
thinking about preparation on a policy
sense though again there's not a lot of
details to point to that but he I think
really dropped the ball preparation for
Donald Trump should have been
maintaining his composure on the stage
there's a lot of things you can get away
with on a field of 16 whether it's
having a sip of water repeatedly whether
it's sort of sniffling whether it is
saying words like Bigley twice which I
think people here when it's the one of
only two voices on stage so I think he
dropped the ball there he was rightly
pointed out that his body language he
was slumping at times there was a moment
when Hillary Clinton started talking
about race relations and he sort of
seemed to fall over the microphone and
emit an audible sigh those are just sort
of things that I think Hillary Clinton
when we talk about debate it's about
more than just having the binders with
the issues and going through the mock
try to beit's with you know Stanton's
for your opponent it's about having
advanced technologically advanced setups
where you've got multiple cameras you've
got multiple monitors people you know
Hillary looking essentially in a mirror
to see what she looks like when she's
listening having a good listening face I
think those are elements of her
performance that she really excelled in
and where I don't think there's a good
excuse for why Donald Trump wasn't
better prepared as far as material and
issues my sense was that the birther
question
was the worst for Trump in that he could
not really explain anything nor even
really answer the question what's your
sense of of of whether I mean do you
agree with me on that is there some
other moment that you find to be the
most destructive for Trump I think that
was a rambling disorganized answer of
the highest order even by Trump
standards I mean he was referencing
journalists that had been dispatched by
various campaigns to crackdown leads
supposedly in the birther issue and then
he sort of again last week you know
calling the press conference to say he
buried this issue and doesn't want
anything to do with it anymore and then
to close in his remarks about the
birther issue by saying you know he did
an American a service for the country by
making sure this issue was brought up in
the debate I mean yeah real pages
clearly doesn't want to divorce himself
from this issue when push comes to shove
I think his real unforced error was on
taxes again it may not have made a huge
splash during the debate but it's going
to be easy fodder for Hillary Clinton he
essentially admitting sort of in a
roundabout way at multiple points that
he may not be paying federal taxes and
that if he were it would have been
squandered no Donald Trump it's been
sort of an amazing thing that for all
his privilege and the openings that you
and I might see for him to be sort of
dink for that that he hasn't been a big
liability for him but this is one of
those issues where he seemed to admit
that he is sort of living by a second
batch of standards that most Americans
don't enjoy and most of us don't get to
choose whether or not we pay our taxes
based upon some sort of a judgment of
whether or not they're going to be used
to our liking that's essentially what
donald trump admitted so i think that
was there's a whole tremendous lexicon
of ways you can punt issues like your
health records or your taxes almost
indefinitely in politics some of those
answers are sort of BS at the end of the
day but there are a lot of excuses you
can things you can say to just sort of
forestall that issue for him to revert
into sort of introducing a new problem
area an area for concern on this tax
issue I think was a a big mistake on his
part so there was this moment during the
debate yesterday when Donald Trump said
it was a again like most of the things
he said it didn't really make a lot of
sense but he
said something like you know it crossed
my mind to say something really tough
about Hillary Clinton but I'm not doing
it because of some moral reason he gave
that he just thought it wouldn't be
right but after the debate he since said
that he might hit harder at the next
debate is there any consensus as to
whether thats related to a bit bill and
hillary clinton's marital past is it
related to i mean what what might that
mean well bear mind he talked about
inviting various guests to this debate
who would get under hillary clinton's
skin about Bill Clinton's extramarital
alleged extramarital affairs there were
you know he made a threat during the
republican convention in fact that there
was going to be a video that was going
to play sort of a feature video i think
it was on night one or two that was
going to explore bill clinton's
escapades and they ended up shelving
that so it seems to be sort of something
he keeps forestalling i'm sure you know
he probably has some good lines
chambered on that and he may try to
exploit that in a debate to come but he
seems to be unwilling to do it at any
one time you're right he pointed out
that thing saying sort of i could have
gone on the attack against the family he
also had a strange line and i wish i had
the quote but he sort of said you know I
I'm do some credit for not exploiting
the minorities who are renting
apartments from me it's as if yeah
Hillary Clinton could could probably go
through a list and say well I could have
killed this guy or could have ordered a
drone strike on this guy but I didn't so
you should applaud me I'm nests or the
kind of logic Trump was operating on I
think he may have more stuff to come but
is he running out of time to exploit
those I think that's a very good
question how soon might we be able to
see what if any was the electoral or
polling impact of yesterday's debate I
mean usually polls are done over a
sampling of two or three days which i'm
guessing could start as early as today
and then a few days after that we would
see some polling data is monday
reasonable i think so at this point
though I will say I'm not putting a
whole lot of stock on national
head-to-heads or national four-way polls
at this point I think the biggest thing
is going to decide this is Hillary
Clinton getting turnout among her core
constituencies which are minorities
women
young voters and I think the biggest
thing that she did yesterday was get
young voters back on her side it goes
down to her preparation the way she was
able to bait Donald Trump the 28
interruptions that have been cut into an
excellent video by the Clinton campaign
which are going viral being shared with
a lot of young people who need to be
showing up for Hillary Clinton I think
her performance really was much more
targeted at making sure that third
pillar of her electoral strategy is
solid and that's a power young people
that are not going to be represented all
that well in national polls so i'd say
maybe let's look at polls in
battleground states where things are
closed Pennsylvania Ohio Michigan
Virginia perhaps but at least at this
point I don't think national polls are
really going to give us a full picture
of things I think Hillary Clinton move
the ball pretty far down the field
yesterday but in a way that might be
masked by polls I think it's a lot of
the work that she did so important for
her electoral strategy is sort of behind
the scenes it's about sort of changing
the mindsets of people but not really
switching who it is they're supporting
all right luke vargas united nations
bureau chief for talk media news thanks
as always Luke thank you David bye-bye